hey guys my name is David Thomas and I'm
the founder of wire watches today I'm
going to show you how to set up the
midnight collection timepiece in this
video I'll teach you how to connect the
strap to the watch how to adjust the
date and the time and also how to make
sure the mesh and metal strap fits your
wrist perfectly so let's get started
all midnight collection timepieces come
with a quick-release band to remove
simply pull the lever on the back side
to replace it with the same or a
different strap the process is the same
as the original collection align the pin
at the top with the hole at the top of
the watch pull the pin and slide in
until you hear a click once you hear it
click make sure it's secure and you're
good to go to change the date push the
crown in all the way and unclick at once
spin the crown and the date should
change accordingly when you're ready
pull the crown out once more and you
should be able to adjust the time to
your current location after you finished
push the crown back in all the way and
your watch is set to adjust the length
of the mesh strap open the butterfly
clip take the tools supplied with the
watch and insert it into the hole
leverage it backwards and up at the same
time and it should click open slide the
clip to your current resize and close it
by pushing firmly back down
to remove links from a metal strap take
note of the directional arrows on the
back insert the tool supplied with the
watch in the holes tap lightly until the
pin appears on the other side once it
does remove the pin completely and the
link should fall out take as many links
out as you need and once you're happy
place the pin back in to connect the
final links tap lightly with a hammer
and secure it to the watch when you're
ready